dix établissements enregistré bonjour
est permis dans ce premier épisode de sa
jusqu alors ce qui nous interpelle
aujourd'hui c'est une éternelle question
qui refait surface avec la une du 13
février des économistes de right way to
the box ou encore bertrand dautzenberg
pneumologue qui a pris la défense
légalisation du cannabis et à quelques
semaines un pneumologue ça le sli or
cela fait quelques années qu'on sait le
traitement de ce sujet par les
politiques français il est un peu fumeux
je vous rappelle les propos de valérie
pécresse il ya quelques mois la région
financera la réalisation de tests au
cannabis dans les lycées ok faire des
tests de drogue ça l'hiver dans les
établissements scolaires je voulais même
pas rentrer dans le détail de pourquoi
c'est pas possible je vais faire quand
même tellement c'est jouissif
déjà il faut l'accord des étudiants on
ne peut pas obliger un test salivaire
sans motif surtout concédé par sos
drogue info service qui n'est ni une
autorité judiciaire ni policière
personne va accepter à part peut-être à
maurice mais toujours au premier rang en
cours de latin bon courage avec ça
ensuite ce test n'a aucun effet après un
simple par le boucher et ça si c'est
interdit
je peux bien que sakho sera beaucoup
plus de dégâts que la légalisation du
cannabis
cette déclaration a pourrait être
anecdotique mais elle représente
aujourd'hui une énième maladresse du
gouvernement face à une consommation de
cannabis en france qui ne parvient pas
en est gay petit rappel des faits de la
france aujourd'hui elle pénalise la
consommation la vente et la production
cannabis sur son territoire et pourtant
nous faisons aujourd'hui partie des plus
gros consommateurs de cannabis en europe
selon un rapport de 2011 dans le mois on
avait 12,7 pour cent des 15 24 ans en
france qui consommait du cannabis contre
5 3% aux pays-bas
et c'est pareil pour son accès 49% de la
population française il ya déjà goûté
alors qu'aux pays bas où la consommation
est légal la part de la population et
l'ayant déjà testé n'est que de 25 7%
je vous rappelle qu'à amsterdam on a
quand même dans une seule ville 220
coffee shops 1 si vous pensez qu'on y
vend du café je vous déconseille très
fortement dallas amsterdam 10 book en
fait la consommation est tellement forte
en france qu'on peut établir une carte
de la consommation des drogues et pas
par un sondage ipsos par le biais de nos
égouts alors je veux que la prochaine
fois que vous aurez envie de vous
plaindre vous repensez à ces personnes
dont le travail a été de faire le tour
d'une station d'épuration pour amasser
des échantillons d'uriné et de sel
pensez-y la prochaine fois vous croirait
avoir un travail de merde
du coup il ya un constat clair la
politique de répression des marches pas
du tout on a eu un mois et chaque année
à 4 millions de personnes qui s'en tape
malgré 568 millions d'euros chaque année
consacrée à la répression dans 300
millions rien que pour les
interpellations
on reste dans le top des consommateurs
européens alors plusieurs pays ont
renoncé au tout répressif d'autres ont
même commencé à mettre en place des
filières du cannabis comme certains
états américains
mais en france on est très loin de tout
ça la france a fait même partie des cinq
derniers pays l'union européenne qui
considère l usage comme une infraction
pénale
et ça entraîne plusieurs conséquences
déjà les coûts pour l'état qui se
répercute sur nos impôts
ensuite les filières criminelles qui se
financent par ce biais et enfin les
enjeux sanitaires sans contrôle comment
on peut s'assurer de la qualité de ce
qu'ils fument et le fait qu'ils aient
des millions d'infractions là dessus
voilà c'est une chose qu'on le fait
qu'ils aient des gens qui prennent des
risques sanitaires ça c'en est une autre
lorsque ceci étant dit leur effet un
contrôle qualité moi j'ai plus cher
parce que ça peut intéresser
c'est pas parce que c'est naturel qui
est pas de même de santé déjà il ya la
façon qu'on apprend du cannabis
généralement le fûmes sauf qu'on était
un abysse ils brûlent moins que le tabac
est produit davantage de gaz carbonique
fumer un joint équivaut à fumer entre
2,5 et 5 cigarettes de suite si vous
avez encore un doute fumer tue et plus
de 70000 français chaque année c'est nul
après il ya le cannabis en lui-même une
étude de 2012 mené pendant 40 ans nous
dit qu'un effet irréversibles sur le
cuit quand on en prend jeunes et pas que
parce qu'on est une autre étude de
l'ugta qui nous parle d'une diminution
du cortex préfrontal dans cette zone
responsable pour les fonctions
cognitives
donc en gros il ya de vrais effets sur
le cerveau chez les moins de 21 ans et
je vous parle même pas de tout ce qui
est psy cause paranoïa augmentation du
risque par trois devenir ciseaux freine
on va pas se mentir c'est peut-être
coule sur le coup mais tu peux
rapidement développé une addiction
galère avec tam et moi ta concentration
bref tu peux perdre les pleines
capacités ton cerveau c'est la drogue et
la drogue c'est mal mon loyer mais après
faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte haussier c'est mal mais est-ce
que c'est plus mal que ce qui n'est pas
interdit pour des raisons historiques ou
culturelles l'alcool et le tabac sont
licites en france alors qu'en termes de
santé publique
il s'agit des premières causes de
mortalité dans le pays avec
l'hypertension le cannabis arrive que
très loin derrière ça c'est une carte
des drogues d'air et on voit bien que le
cannabis est sous l'alcool et le tabac
en termes de dégâts physiques et de
dépenses tant d'ailleurs l'ecstasy
apparemment ça a l'air pas mal
alors est ce qu a que du mauvais dans le
cannabis est pas un nom en la
consommation de cannabis et peut aussi
apporter de nom
gros effets positifs c'est elle est
encadrée par un médecin a administré par
vaporisation par spray par comprimé ou
même par suppositoire parce que oui un
[ __ ] de projets de suppositoire au
cannabis qui est à l'étude pour lutter
contre les douleurs des règles oui
suppôts quoi alors antidouleur
analgésiques ou anticonvulsif
disparition des nausées il ya plein d
usage et particulièrement auprès des
patients sous chimiothérapie ou atteints
de sclérose en plaques donc c'est hyper
important
et d'ailleurs l'apparition d'un
médicament dérivé du cannabis ça pue le
sativex a même failli arriver en france
se sont pas mis d'accord sur le prix
donc pour l'instant c'est dans les
limbes ne seront qu on n'arrive pas à
négocier à côté du conflit
israélo-palestinien et de certaines
séries sur netflix et si vous m'entendez
soyez sérieux priorité netflix pour
revenir sur les apports potentiels
aux etats unis ils sont même allés plus
loin en des entreprises comme flower et
mas route qui sont dans l'industrie
encouragent la consommation pendant
brainstorming pour avoir de nouvelles
idées
si donc on se rend compte que le
cannabis c'est pas forcément le démon et
qui a peut-être des choses à en tirer
sans parler du fait qu'il ya un décalage
profond entre les habitudes des français
et les lois du coup s'en aller à
l'encouragement dans les entreprises
pendant les sessions par une standing on
se rend compte qu'il ya clairement un
problème alors c'est quoi les solutions
qu'on a à nos dispositions
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'à deux
manières dans notre ligue ce problème
est de ne plus être dans une
interdiction simple et à la
dépénalisation et la légalisation
d'abord la dépénalisation spoiler rien à
voir avec le retrait de la famille le
pen dans la dépénalisation des usages
c'est renoncer à punir pénalement
l'usagé d'un produit ou du moins baisser
le niveau de l'infraction
pour le consommateur ça veut pas dire
que tout est autorisé mais c'est comme
pour la gueule en fait c'est pas un
délit des dessous mais l'ivresse
publique ou l'alcool au volant c'est
interdit le premier avantage c'est l'
impact direct sur le coût la répression
qui est réduit et sur les tribunaux qui
sont des encore j'ai des petits délits
de consommation et quand on connaît le
problème de l'engorgement des tribunaux
en france
c'est un point intéressant après
forcément la question qui se pose c'est
de savoir si le fait de dépénaliser le
produit peut entraîner une augmentation
de la consommation parce qu'on peut
imaginer qu'une partie de la
consommation adolescente s'effectue dans
une logique de transgression de la loi
et que du coup si on autorise le
cannabis il s'orienterait tous vers des
drogues plus nocif en gros qu'il y à un
glissement des drogues et ben on n'a
qu'à regarder ce que les pays qui ont
pénalisés on fait quoi aux pays bas la
consommation du cannabis
elle est tolérée elle n'a jamais explosé
c'est pareil pour le portugal qui
aujourd'hui fait partie de ceux qui
comptent le moins de consommateurs
d'europe et j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête un
moment sur le portugal le nombre
d'héroïnomanes a baissé de 60% en une
décennie
et d'après le rapport de 2009 de
l'institut de la drogue et la
toxicomanie
le portugal est le pays où la
consommation de cannabis des 15 64 ans
est la plus faible d'europe avec -2 8%
et c'est pas avec la consommation de
cocaïne et même chez nous avant la loi
de 1970 le hpv la marijuana était
autorisée et on en consomme est quatre
fois moins qu'aujourd'hui
donc on peut pas lier si facilement la
dépénalisation avec une augmentation de
la consommation
après il ya une seconde alternative
c'est la légalisation
en gros on donne un cadre légal à un
produit ou une activité
donc c'est pas du tout une liberté
totale ça peut être un cadre restrictif
par exemple déjà on peut limiter le type
de consommateur c'est ce qui se passe en
suisse ou en californie
c'est que pour résoudre c'est que pour
un usage pendant thérapeutique du coup
si vous allez à venice beach
vous verrez des docteurs très sérieux
qui vous ferons une évaluation médicale
pour 30 dollars
l'état peut aussi faire comme l'uruguay
en 2013 en nationalisant sa production
et sa distribution alors l'avantagent de
cette option c'est surtout de rapporter
beaucoup de zahia l'état avec des
recettes fiscales estimées à 1,8
milliard et ça peut aller
hyper loin le colorado s'est même
retrouvé avec trop de recettes sur les
bras liés au cannabis avec 30 millions $
de plus que ce qui était prévu et c'est
pas qu'une question monétaire n'est
qu'une question de qualité puisque en
termes de sécurité la légalisation d'un
permet aussi de diminuer les trafics via
des prix bas au départ pour casser les
réseaux puis en augmentant
progressivement les prix avant il ya des
alternatives sérieuses le mois prochain
tomb marisol touraine fin novembre
qui nous dit je ne suis pas favorable à
ce qu'on mettre ce débat sur la table
aujourd'hui
maintenant le droit tel qu'il est il me
semble pas judicieux comme message
envoyé de dire qu'au fond le cannabis
c'est pas si grave que ça sabre ouf
alors support prendre des ponts la
dépénalisation et la légalisation du
cannabis
voici en train de vous dire c'est que
t'as 40 % des français qui ont déjà
goûté ça on est l'un des premiers pays
d'europe qui en consomment c'est en
hausse
ça vaut peut-être le coup d'en discuter
et faire la politique de l'autruche va
pas nous aider
tu as beaucoup de pays qui ont pris les
devants on a des éléments qui nous
prouve qu'il ya du bon dans ses
solutions là et quand bertrand
dautzenberg
pneumologue et relance le débat est là
profitons-en pour nous poser les bonnes
questions
alors non en le cannabis c'est pas le
truc tout plein de la terre et c'est pas
trop mal que les sociétés en contrôlent
l'accès un minimum mais sérieusement
pénalisation d'un produit consommé par
autant de monde achetable aussi
facilement moins nocif que beaucoup
d'autres produits légaux et qui a même
des vertus thérapeutiques
mais dans la vente alimente bang et
trafics en tous genres non selon pas
super et j'ai l'impression d'être face à
un mec qui continue de commander la
salade au mcdo pour prendre soin de son
corps affronteront le problème il faut
commencer par renouer le dialogue avec
la jeunesse a relu les étiqueter
génération y ou z
au lieu de ça on a quoi des débats sur
la déchéance de nationalité dont on se
branlent complet là on parle d'un
problème qui fait que tu as 12 % des
français qui sont régulièrement en
infraction on parle de gosses qui savent
pas ce qu'ils fument on parle de malades
qui peuvent pas se soulager
on parle de trafiquants qui fondent et
une sur tout ça et ça ça c'est un
problème concret la france a toujours
été en avance sur beaucoup de choses
maintenant évident qu'on est en retard
j'espère que ce premier épisode vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à le partager et
à lâcher un pouce en l'air si vous
voulez en voir d'autres
vous pouvez me suivre sur tous les
réseaux facebook comme flash ball
chenôve twitter.com score et snapshot
merci à tous les types heures vous êtes
vraiment formidable vous pouvez vous
aussi soutenir financièrement le projet
sur petit du tout comme cela furious
love et surtout abonnez vous pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos love une
piste